I'm curious if you've taught your kids
anything about Star Trek or you're gonna
pass Star Trek on to them you don't care
about Star Trek it's not that I don't
care about Star Trek I just you know
Star Wars and Star Trek were completely
different for me Star Wars had all of
this action and it was you know
fantasies Star Trek was like science and
you know and the action and in science
is like kind of like it's kind of lame
you know I mean like the Millennium
Falcon did all of these spins and
everything and the Starship Enterprise
just went straight not exciting it went
went very slowly right and it's like
full impulse power and the thing's not
even moving them yeah
it's driving around Florida looking for
an Applebee's I actually bought a clip i
you know Star Wars there's a lot of
lightsabers fighting in you know it's
explosions and everything like that Star
Trek
a fighting Star Trek this is what a
start here's maintaining that it's slow
you think it a Star Trek fight is slow
not only is it slow it's boring but
check it out just play the clip all
right
I must type to remember that this is an
intelligent highly advanced individual
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
of course Captain Kirk's gonna look like
a badass the dude swinging like this the
whole time yeah I would fight that alien
eating an ice cream cone
dodging him come on loser guy you can do
better than that
you